well I think with the rumor broke that
we were going to do something bigger
well and I started hearing Rumblings and
then these 39 professors attacked this
is prior to the event and then we
started hearing rumors that the students
were intimidated and threatened if you
show up at that event you know you might
not get a you might not get that grade
you want and so it was intimidation it
was muscle
it was everything we don't stand for
and these I mean I'm not a fond of
Education as you you know from my
history I'd learned nothing about money
at school I had to learn it from my rich
dad who was a high school dropout but
anyway
it was horrifying and I said to Anderson
I told you this would happen but David
it got worse
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
investor entrepreneur and author of Rich
Dad Poor Dad former room report guest
Robert Kiyosaki and Free Speech Advocate
and former executive I put emphasis on
former former executive director of the
Lewis Center at Arizona State University
and Atkinson Robert Mann welcome to the
Reuben report
thank you thank you very much uh Robert
I'm going to start with you because I
put emphasis on former in Anne's intro
but sort of you coming to ASU is what
caused the former part in her intro so
why don't you set us up as to why you
guys are here together and then Ann will
get to your involvement in this whole
thing
well let me go way back in time in 1965
I read this book here The Communist
Manifesto I went to military school I'm
a ring knocker and then I went to
Vietnam as a marine pilot I flew these I
flew these babies in Vietnam
you know shot a lot of Communists out
there
and then I came walking home you know
Johnny Comes Marching Home Again
Air Force Base just North of San
Francisco interesting isn't it
and I'm afraid what's happened to
America is we have gone Marxist
and so when Anne invited me to Arizona
State University which is the largest
university in America I said no way I'm
not going
just because I had such a bad experience
at the University of Hawaii I got spit
on there too
you know I was an MBA program and I
dropped out
so when Aunt asked me would you mind
teaching at ASU I said I'd rather go
back to Vietnam and shoot people as more
honest you know what I mean I'm a sick
Marine you guys understand that and so
she said I promised you I promise I'll
protect you and she did she that was
just a Lewis Center is to Barrett's
Honors College Dave these were the
brightest of the brights you know people
I never hung out with that's cool
and it was a fabulous was it was all an
entrepreneurship I brought my oil guy in
my cattle guy uh my uh 401K I don't I
don't do a 401ks but my stock guy in and
all this stuff it was fabulous and then
says well let's do it again I'm going
okay she sucked me in so that was last
summer this and so December I mean
February we did an event called health
wealth and happiness on Arizona State
campus University
health wealth happiness featuring Dennis
Prager and unfortunately Charlie Kirk
who we as in Marine Marine pilot would
say we drew a lot of fire and and these
Walt professors 39 of them came after us
and Dave it's still we're still fighting
that was last February we're at the
Arizona State Legislature they're taking
action against these 39 professors for
intimidation threats I can't believe how
Marxist and woke they've gotten and and
got fired because of it right so Robert
you called me a couple weeks ago said
have you heard about this story I
started doing some Googling it really
was sort of blowing up in Arizona but
hasn't kind of made it national that's
why I wanted to talk to you guys about
this because first off this one the free
everyone knows me in free speech but
then this one felt personal because
Robert we're friends and then you're on
stage with two of my other buddies
Dennis who's become like a an uncle to
me and Charlie who's a good buddy of
mine these are not haters These are not
mean evil people and you're talking
about success and wealth and happiness
all of these things these are not far
right crazy mean racist things uh so
Anne can you explain a bit about uh why
you invited them and then what the
pushback was that kind of led to the
whole brouhaha and now how it's gotten
involved with the state legislature even
yes Dave I will so for the last two
years I've been the executive director
of the TW Lewis Center for personal
development which is a center of the
Honors College at Arizona State Barrett
has 7 000 students and the purpose of
the Lewis Center was to teach those
students about entrepreneurship Career
Success happiness personal finance and
meaning but also to teach the
traditional American values of personal
responsibility hard work civic duty
faith family and community service so in
my role as executive director we put on
and I oversaw programming for the
students and in the last two years we
had nearly 150 programs this was one of
them the topics of health wealth and
happiness were directly aligned with the
intent of the Lewis Center which was
established by ASU in its Honors College
so with this event we decided to have a
normal Lewis Hunter speaker program but
to make it available to the public the
Lewis Center is not a political Medical
Center this was not even a political
program but health wealth and happiness
led to censorship condemnation and
chilling and ultimately my firing and
the firing of the person for the event
venue who put this on on our behalf okay
so Robert you guys show up to the event
it's a public event at the school when
did you realize that there were going to
be some problems were they were they
shouting you down at the beginning of
the event were there protests before and
when did it sort of escalate into
something other than just the usual
stuff that happens on college campuses
well I think with the rumor broke that
we were going to do something bigger
well and I started hearing Rumblings and
then these 39 professors attacked this
is prior to the event and then we
started hearing rumors that the students
were intimidated and threatened if you
show up at that event you know you might
not get a you might not get that grade
you want and so it was intimidation it
was muscle
it was everything we don't stand for and
these I mean I'm not a fond of Education
as you know from my history I learned
nothing about money at school I had to
learn it from my rich dad who was a high
school dropout but anyway
it was horrifying and I said to Annas I
I told you this would happen but David
it got worse and these guys is there's a
saying that the Japanese Chinese and any
educated person says if you find
yourself in a hole stop digging well
these dumbass 39 professors keep digging
and they're still digging and that's the
the Arizona sense that Arizona Senate is
now doing an investigation into them and
this the head of the Senate said there
will be people being fired there's
nothing more terrifying to a professor
like my poor dad than being fired okay
so and these 39 professors did they show
up to the event I mean they were telling
their kids in essence before the event
do not show up or it's going to hurt
your grade like how and do you have
records of this kind of stuff
I have records of everything the 39 out
of the 47 honors faculty ran this
National condemnation Campaign which
started with their petition that called
Dennis Prager and Charlie Kirk white
nationalist provocateurs bigoted extreme
anti-intellectual anti-democratic
purveyors of hate who've publicly
attacked women people of color the lgbtq
community and so forth and then Robert
was accused of being dangerous because
he teaches about debt
about debt you are dangerous to debt
Robert
I I say debt and taxes make the rich
richer you know I don't pay tax like
Donald Trump you know we're real estate
guys the teachers went nuts so this
didn't end though with a petition to
their Deans the professors went into
their classroom where they teach
mandatory honors classes to freshmen to
condemn our program our speakers our
donors and the leadership and staff of
the Lewis Center the professors used ASU
resources computers equipment and their
official capacity to do so which was
which leads to State action that is a
state actionable offense the professors
went campus-wide outside of the Honors
College for help to drive a mission to
condemn all of those parties and then
they went further on a national
condemnation campaign painting this and
labeling this as hate speech
okay so Robert I hate to tell you that
I'm when you called me about this I
think I said to you on the phone I'm not
surprised right like there's nothing
that would surprise me about any sane
person showing up to a university and
being told that they were evil and all
that stuff right right I think what
surprises people to some extent still is
that is how much of this comes from
faculty because I think most people are
used to seeing the kids go crazy now
like everyone's kind of used to blue
haired students screaming somebody down
uh but and what you're connecting to
this too is the faculty so so well how I
guess from here how did you end up as
former director and then we'll go from
there yes and I I'll add Dave it's not
just the faculty the dean's censored
speech The deans of my college spent
censored speech they told me Robert
Kiyosaki Dennis Prager and Dr Radha
gopalan who were on the panel were only
to talk about health wealth and
happiness and they were not to speak
about higher education or anything that
could be deemed political or used as a
political platform wow so and a
university that's celebrated for its
Free Speech policies College Deans
undermine that by saying what speech was
allowed and what speech wasn't allowed
further the Deans pulled down all the
marketing from the walls around the
Barrett Honors College complex citing it
was offending the faculty and that's why
they discriminated against our speech
and they allowed opposing faculty to
Market an opposition event that painted
our event as dangerous hate speech so it
was faculty and administration but how
does that get to you being former
director of the center
yes well this was the perfect
opportunity for the new Dean at Barrett
the Honors College to eradicate the
values that are evidently no longer
allowed at the college so after the
faculty attacked our donor Tom Lewis our
main donor and our other donors the
Lewis Center the after the Barrett Deans
mishandled the situation our main donor
Mr Tom Lewis who's donated millions of
dollars to Arizona State over the last
two decades left the faculty scared him
out so I brought in new Diversified
donor funding to keep the intent of the
Lewis Center going which back to the
first part of our conversation included
things like personal responsibility hard
work faith family community service the
new Dean took this opportunity to
dismantle a gem at the Honors College
and she said the funding is gone
therefore we need to fire you yet and
between the time when Tom Lewis notified
the college he would be terminating and
the time that actually took effect I
brought in new Diversified donor funding
the dean turned down so ASU is stuck
firmly to the position on this that we
lost donor funding therefore my position
as executive director goes with it but
they're not saying that Dean explicitly
turns down new funding she didn't ask
who are the donors let's have a
conversation meet with the ASU
Foundation she was purely not interested
so she fired me effective June 30 when
Tom Lewis's funding ended and dismantled
a gem at asu's Honors College and
eradicated these values that are
obviously no longer aligned with the
college yeah wow I mean this really does
sound like another version of what
happened to Brett Weinstein up at
Evergreen and has happened to a whole
bunch of other professors and faculty at
colleges across the country Robert did
anything happen at the event I mean so
you guys do the event I mean were kids
outraged Did anyone say anything that
was untoward did you scare anybody with
talk of debt
what Dave the problem was the students
loved us you know of course the students
protesting these students showed up in
Mass they were happy they sent all that
it turned out great because Carrie Lake
took you know she was ran for governor
she had the the same ballot bot Ballot
Box Boogie that uh Trump has you know
different topic different topic I know
but anyway so Carrie stepped up and it
was an overwhelming success because the
community stepped up
and and again I'll I'll write this I
flew this for the US Marine Corps I'm
not the brightest guy on Earth they said
don't be political so I showed up in my
Marine flight flight jacket and I I held
this book up for all the teachers and I
said you guys should read this book and
find out who you are so it went off the
rails from there Dave
and can you tell me a little bit more
about the the teachers I mean are these
across disciplines are they did you have
a sense of what all their political
leanings were have any of them now
realizing that this is becoming a story
have any of them retracted some of the
things they've said or anything like
that
well certainly the uh the teacher who
had multiple students provide
testimonies to the Joint legislative
session confirming that she used her
classroom to tell them not to attend the
program she's put out a public statement
denying it but she doesn't know there
are recordings from within her
classrooms that confirm the opposite of
what she did what she's doing she might
know that now
look the teachers the teachers study all
sorts of topics those that are leading
this kind of nation effort they study
witchcraft the practice teaching of
Witchcraft they study gender Theory
Colonials or subtler colonialism gun
culture but look my view is they have
the right to do that if they want to
have an event on witchcraft and students
want to attend I support that I think
our programs are slightly better
attended but I think we all have a place
in higher education to provide something
different so the professors have a range
of backgrounds they're they teach
freshmen they're they're technically
lecturers so they're not full professors
at ASU but they have just collectively
shamed this speech health wealth and
happiness and the values of the Lewis
Center is hateful and dangerous and and
so so what exactly is going on now with
the state legislature related to all
this because obviously the school gets
State funding I'm sure there's all sorts
of connections between the school and
the state
that's right well it's really
unfortunate what is needed to happen is
I've been taking the last several months
to address these concerns internally
I've gone through all the proper ASU
channels I even went to the president of
the university in the entire Board of
Regents with a summary of basically what
I testified about in our hearing this
week the answer the the university told
me we allowed the speakers but you then
have to take the consequences and when I
address the toxicity that's come around
Barrett since our new Dean came on board
a year ago they said it was my fault for
inviting the speakers they didn't say
it's a weak leader that brought with her
a vacuum to the Honors College that
allowed the speed The Faculty to run
rampant so I exhausted all options to
address things internally with my alma
mater and unfortunately it's taking
legislative action so to answer your
question Dave there was an ad hoc joint
session between the Arizona State Senate
and House of Representatives this
Tuesday July 18th and they investigated
this free speech crisis at ASU Robert
was there for the whole thing I
testified another professor Dr Owen
Anderson testified in support of free
speech Seth leepsen testified and Dennis
Prager even came here from California to
testify in his defense so we had this ad
hoc hearing a five and a half hour long
hearing to present the facts ASU is
still denying that there was any
wrongdoing I think generally ASU has
great Free Speech policies and I keep
saying we have one of the most free
speech presidents in the pro-free speech
presidents in the country but all of
this is undermining those policies so
what happens next the Senate Judiciary
Committee in the state of Arizona is
taking this up they have ordered a
60-day a deadline for Arizona State to
report on the information presented and
they'll determine next steps upon
receiving that report in 60 days Robert
as as the sort of Outsider here what do
you want to happen because I sense a
little bit of kind of shout in Freud
with you on this it's like I know you
well enough you don't think that a kid
needs the four-year education and and
the debt and all of that stuff to become
successful so I can sense in a certain
way you're sort of like well of course
this happens this is the ridiculous way
that the American education system works
or or does not work
well that teachers who teach witchcraft
didn't show up because they couldn't
Park the Brahms
I know I got kicked out of school
because I'm a wise ass you can't go
after witches man but that's that's the
line that's dangerous yeah
Dave this is the story of Rich Dad Poor
Dad magnified a thousand percent my poor
dad was a very very good man
but at the core I Marxist
and they're not bad people and I I
support the freedom to choose
but they don't know they are they don't
know there are and they talk about you
know America was founded not in 1619
like the New York Times wants us to
believe America was founded in
1773. it's called the Boston Tea Party
you know and I fight for freedom of of
uh taxes and marks as a progressive
income tax is essential for the spread
of Communism
if you read this book here
you know I wrote this book here
encountered to us called the capitalist
Manifesto because I am a U.S marine I'm
Academy graduate and I fight for the
freedom of principle I don't fight for
people I've look for a principle allow
us our freedom of speech well and
clearly you could see why a guy like him
would be considered controversial at
Arizona State you know guys as a total
sidebar you will love this about seven
years ago I spoke at Arizona State
University with Michael Shermer who you
might know from uh skeptic magazine and
at the end of all my talks I always say
to the audience if you disagree with me
you can come up and ask questions first
and as a joke at the beginning of the
talk I said you know how many liberals
are here how many conservatives here I
said how by raise a hand how many Nazis
are here and one woman raised her hand
in the back and said she was a Nazi so I
said at the end during the Q a if you
don't shout me down you can ask the
first question it turned out she was
actually a trans Nazi yes believe it or
not a trans-nazi and she didn't believe
that the gas Chambers existed and a
whole bunch of other stuff and Michael
Shermer who debunks these things did and
we had an incredible uh event on Free
Speech where we debated things and I
don't know that we changed the trans not
these mind but that's my memory of
Arizona State so that's why this is so
uh this morning so so Anne what what do
you want to happen now I mean I suppose
you want do you want these professors to
be let go I mean do you want your job
back
well I don't want my job back I've
already explored that with with
University leadership I'm I'm clearly
not welcome uh certainly at bear at the
Honors College
um look ASU the world is watching this
has become a national story ASU is an
example in free speech and they need to
make it clear what they will and won't
tolerate right now ASU is sending a
message to The Faculty majority that
it's okay to bully suppress intimidate
and censor speech they're sending a
message to people like me who run
centers or programs in the ideological
minority that you better not speak up
because you will risk condemnation
retaliation and you probably will lose
your job so I I really I've been trying
to appeal to the better people in ASU to
take action to actually investigate but
yet in these months no one has asked me
once for more information for a
conversation where they can to ask
questions so I'm hoping that ASU will
step in but it might take action from
the Arizona State Legislature it might
take action from the Arizona Board of
Regents but this simply is a disgrace to
one of the great universities in our
country and are you getting uh I think
you sort of just answered this but I I
know when when Brett was dealing with
all of the craziness at Evergreen he
kept telling me privately how so many
professors were supporting him privately
but nobody would step up and say
anything publicly I I assume you're
getting some version of that I think you
kind of alluded to that
exactly and they're they're afraid to
speak out and this it's not just the
professors actually more students have
reached out to me than professors and
the students say look I I want to go
meet with the dean but I'm afraid I'm
going to risk my grades or my living
arrangements or have some retaliation if
I do so the professors created a Culture
of Fear around this event because they
painted it as a white supremacy event
keep in mind Robert you're a hell of a
white supremacist
Dennis Prager is a religious Jew Dr
radical pollen was raised in Sri Lanka
and yet I had to defend comparisons to
the KKK in a meeting with my Dean
the events operations manager who was
fired the venue was asked by the
executive director of ASU gamet why did
you allow a white supremacist on our
stage
so they're silencing the students with
this climate of fear so it's the
students that are really the concerning
people that have been reaching out in
droves to express their their support
for this but their fear of Retribution
so Robert I know as a capitalist you
like to create rather than destroy
you've got a couple bucks what about
creating a new free speech center at a
more free speech friendly uh College
we've got a couple of them here in
Florida by the way
you're reading my mind David you're
reading my mind you know there was an
old that was an old movie about Torah
Torah Tara about my ancestors I was on
the American side they attacked Pearl
Harbor
and and then this um Japanese Yamato
after you after he bombed Pearl Harbor
he says he says I think we're just
pissed off the Americans
and now these teachers have pissed me
off yeah so I'm going to come after him
yeah I mean you just gotta fight back
well and as I said to you right before
we started you know I've been through
this conversation some version of it
many times on my show some people don't
expect to be in the fight some people
don't want to be in the fight and they
end up in it anyway I sense that you're
ready to be in it and you're gonna see
this thing through huh I am fully
immersed and fully committed to
supporting an environment that really
allows free speech for all viewpoints so
I I'll speak with with other media I
will continue this Mission until there's
a resolution
um I I hope you can see I'm not
criticizing ASU I'm simply highlighting
gross undermining of these policies that
that suppresses so many people in the
community so if I have a role to play in
this I'm game where can we point people
to if they want more information on
what's going on or maybe how they can
help that sort of thing
sure thing
I'm send gmail.com I don't yet have
fancy media contacts but I suppose maybe
we'll set something up okay we'll we'll
post some links down below and Robert
what's next on your uh freedom fighting
Frontier
well like I said I'm gonna promote this
book even more like I did at ASU I
should people should read this book do
you know what I mean if you're selling
more communist manifestos than anybody
it's really ironic
I I'm an author you know but
if I could write a book this powerful
I'd be proud of myself but this is it's
written in 1848 David it's more true
today than ever before and what this
book says that communism would take over
America in two stages the first stage
happened in 1930 when Columbia
University where Dennis program went to
school
they invited in professors from the the
Communist League of Germany and so these
Communists came into Columbia University
in 1930
and from there rioting spread to schools
all across the country so when I was at
school I went to the academy in Kansas
Point emergency Academy
there was rioting at Columbia University
and then there was Kent State and all
that and you know Berkeley
and rioting has spread across the
country unfortunately those
students are now professors
you know so I jokingly say that when I
was standing I came back to North from
North to Norton Air Force Base I flew in
from Vietnam I brought my 16 men home
all alive I'm getting hit on spit on hit
with eggs and all this stuff and I
jokingly say because as you may guess
most of my audience is apparently
conservative
I certainly say you know I look in those
audience of you know students my age the
hippie generation the the Woodstock
generation throwing eggs at me I said I
swear to God that was Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck sure
but I think they became our leaders
David
does that make sense to you no it it
does make sense we clearly see what the
universities have done from way back
then to exactly right now which is the
whole point of the book that you're
holding that to be clear you did not
write but you're promoting you're
promoting it for all the wrong reasons I
get why now promote your own book so
that people understand the antidote to
that lunacy
well I just wrote this this how big it
had to be just to respond at how
communism exactly this book said it
could come in two stages he predicted it
Mark was a 1848 the second was when the
ballot boxes were taken from Donald
Trump was my friend of mine and the
Trump and I wrote two books together
excuse me
so our freedom has been taken away and
that's what concerns me David well I
think we just got another great Ally in
the fight my friend because Ann is with
us now and uh this is just the beginning
I'll stay on top of this story and uh
you guys are welcome back anytime
thank you it's not about people it's
about principles let's fight for our
principles
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell